the conference central application
includes both a back-end application
that defines the endpoint functions and
the front-end application that has the
web pages that use those functions
so i'm going to call the back-end
application basically i'm going to refer
to it as the back end api
and the
part of the application that has the web
pages i'm going to refer to as the web
ui now in our case they're all in one
single application got one app id
you deploy the app takes the back end
api and takes the web ui with it
however the web ui and the back end api
don't have to be in the same application
they could be in completely separate
applications or you could even have
multiple applications that provide
different front-end interfaces to the
conference back-end api
so here we've got several different
applications each with a different kind
of web ui
and we have our conference api running
here
on the back end api
however in our case the web ui and the
back end api
are in the same application but app
engine doesn't really care that they're
in the same application you still have
to authorize a front-end ui to access
the backend api
so there's a few things you need to do
before you can start using the web pages
in the conference central application
and these are all around authorizing the
web ui for login and giving the web ui
permission to use the backend api